Okay.
Should be live here. Hello.
I figured I'd do a little stream today.
I'm leaving tomorrow. Um, be traveling
for a bit.
I just had a couple things I wanted to
play with.
All right. So, I've got this little
minimal end
Okay. So, we can see here this is not
optimal, right?
They're all going to the same one.
This can be done much better.
Wacka puff.
I could merge a whacka puff in a bit
here and where are the bigger ends?
Mario and other such such things.
aim trainer.
Yeah.
Is it literally like this? Like this
thing
like
whack a puff like this.
I wonder if you could actually make a
decent RL environment out of this. I It
would actually have to control the mouse
is the thing. It wouldn't just be able
to like the action can't just be click
target obviously.
doesn't play FPS.
I play Runescape. That's like the exact
mouse pattern you use for Runescape. I
can't aim at all in 3D.
Like I'm top few percent though in
Runescape.
Maybe like top two 3%.
Well, this is fun.
You're telling me that this works in um
this actually works in our native, but
it doesn't work in torch.
actually wait what's the default policy?
Isn't it? Um,
two new NPRs.
I'm going to do some of this first and
then we'll see that.
This is super annoying though, isn't it?
Because
if I can't trust this implementation,
Minimal similar to target.
Not really. It's like it looks similar,
but it's a much harder problem.
Okay, I guess this implementation is at
least correct.
It's just not quite as stable.
1.4 mil. Yeah, it's super slow by
comparison, isn't it?
We're just going to play with a couple
little architecture things.
I'm so good under 200 lines. I mean,
that was the point, right?
That was the whole point of that
exercise.
Uh, it could potentially replace torch
init, but I couldn't replace our um our
low-level back And
Interesting that this doesn't work.
Okay.
Well, we're going to if we're going to
be stupid about things,
let's just do um
There it is.
Okay. So, the drive model is
linear layer norm linear. Funny enough.
this this looks like it could be
something.
Um, it's I wouldn't be super surprised
if it worked in I'd be surprised if it
worked and could be made fast.
That's the key.
Well, I'm a bit suspicious now if the
default doesn't like
Oh, no. There it goes.
Oh.
Huh?
Janky
something though.
type of thing will be very slow. We
should try it though.
Okay, now I'm getting suspicious if this
doesn't immediately solve it. Right.
like this you would think would solve
it.
It seems odd to me if this is just not
able to learn at all.
I would think that would mean something
is wrong.
Okay. Well, I'm very suspicious actually
now cuz if if nothing learns this even
remotely well, then there's something
wrong with the torch bind.
Um
The hell would be wrong.
Do I have another end that this like
that works instantly?
Did I break multi-discrete and [ __ ]
torch?
That's really annoying.
[ __ ] torch, man.
I have any other multi-discre I can try
real quick just to make sure it's not
something dumb.
I swear to [ __ ] we tested this before
release.
to look for this stupid thing.
Got to hate torch.
Pearl.
All right.
Okay, there we go. And now we'll be able
to actually compare real [ __ ] Good.
That was annoying.
All right. So, this is the overkill
attention one, right?
but we will see whether overkill
attention off does any better.
Then we'll try his thingy.
Dude, do you not see how ludicrously
overkill this thing is?
What the [ __ ]
This is going to be ludicrous overkill.
Something like this, I'm sure.
Yeah, Liberty.
This looks mega overkill to me.
This is like your typical dog [ __ ] torch
code as well.
You write little tiny block of code and
then you write another little tiny block
of code and then you write another
little tiny block of code. They all
[ __ ] call each other.
Hey, Vault. How's it going, man? You
done with the uh the competition?
This very quickly matches the original
net perf. See if it does any better
though.
Hectic last couple hours.
I'm just fiddling with some architecture
stuff trying to figure out if like um
there's a better way to represent set
observations.
We will see
this thing does um anything decent for
us.
inferno stuff though.
I think I'm going to grab that um that
gift of like the healer skip madness
thing for my uh slide deck. I got some
talks to give in New York.
I booked I will be in New York for
I think just under three days which is
good because I start to go insane after
three days in New York.
Like every single time I take the train
out of New York, it's just like stress
draining out of me.
Damn city.
What's not to like?
It's just like go go go go. But where
the [ __ ] are you going?
That's how I would describe that place.
I've almost had it clear without it
killing Jads or Sets.
You do have to kill Wait, Vault. Don't
you have to kill sets like Ranger at
least?
I don't know how the attack cycle works
with that if you can off tick Jad and
Ranger and Mage.
if you flick perfectly, you don't have
to kill anything really.
Okay, so let's see what this actually
does.
If this is all the code, then this is
potentially
reasonable.
Okay. Well, this is the type of arch
you'd want.
That is eight ticks. That's or four
ticks.
They just spawn nicely. Well, you get to
choose when you
No, you don't get to choose when you add
rogue add because they'll still be on
tick cycle, right?
So yeah, they would have to all line up
nicely. I don't know if Jad lines up
nicely.
I also don't know. Um, so multiple sets,
if there are if you get multiple sets,
then I think that's timing. Wait,
no, they don't line up nicely, man. It's
timing dependent, isn't it?
It depends when you proc them.
Well, even the first set with Jad,
right? Like, doesn't Jad just have some
amount of delay
before he attacks?
I think you could technically set it up
so that they're all off tick nicely,
but you'd have to
you'd basically have to be only
attacking Zuck on the right tick as soon
as you get him into um range of a T-Bo
shot
like to spawn uh Jad.
stun depending on Zuck timing. Okay,
then. I don't know. That seems weird.
doesn't have a Jed there.
Except he doesn't have a Jed. Yeah,
you can do that. It's not any harder to
flick a ton of sets versus one. Oh, so
maybe they do line up then. Or maybe he
lines them up.
Uh, no, there's a pause.
Wait,
no, because there's a pause in there,
right? There's a pause once you
Yeah, there's a pause after a certain HP
threshold.
And the pause is determined by how long
it takes you to hit it to the next HP
threshold.
Yeah, this is a really shitty end. I
don't trust any of these experiments.
I honestly forget what the [ __ ] this
thing even is.
Exactly the same as before, right?
98k.
This actually could help us as well for
um inferno type stuff vault. This thing
cuz um
it's basically the whole set problem of
like I see a bunch of things around me.
How do I represent them?
I don't know if we can do this. We'll
see.
I think we can.
I mean, you can do that, but I don't
think
Like you can make I like reward shaping
in general vault like doing a whole
bunch of reward is a great way to just
burn a bunch of your time and drive
yourself nuts. It's kind of [ __ ]
Well, I think it just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about using the pillars, man.
Look, if we solve it with no pillars,
then great. It does no pillar inferno
and it does the waves also, right? It
[ __ ] up on um it mostly screws up on
bosses.
What I saw
If it were easier, we just do it now.
Yeah. I just generally would not suggest
doing um reward as a method for solving
stuff if you can at all avoid it. Like
you're turning to this as your first
line of defense in a lot of cases where
it should be your last one.
But like what's the current state of it,
right? Um
what's the current best runs you have?
Stupid [ __ ] model. I swear.
This Zillers,
do you have the checkpoint at Ziller's
vault?
cuz I added I added checkpointing
ability where you can just start from
the damn Zuck healers.
mostly organic.
Uh mostly Twitter Liberty
curriculum in general is pretty strong.
So that's why 50 is about curriculum. 50
is going to just do all that for us.
computer on something else. We can get
you a box.
Speaking of which, I got to actually
reboot all the boxes today just to make
sure that um the tail scale stuff is
stable.
Interesting. So, this actually takes
quite a hit to perf here
with this one.
Um, this is not anywhere near as good as
before.
can do research stuff on MacBook while
training on box.
Is it? All right, let me get you a Let
me get you a form.
This is called the one page I will not
do bad things on cluster form.
Where's my thing? Where's my DM thread
with you? [ __ ] Do I not have one?
Are we safe from any DMCA or whatever?
What? Any DMCA
for What?
I think you can just replace soft max
with sigmoid.
Okay, so this is interesting though that
this actually gives
We could consider adding back the
original thing here.
fortunately doesn't work very well. Oh,
hello. I'm working on um
essentially we have some environments
that need order and variant observations
and we're messing with a couple little
like semi-attentional architectures.
I don't know if any of these will work
and I definitely don't know if we can
make any of them fast.
It's kind of been this tricky persistent
problem of how do you handle egocentric
setbased observations?
If we had a good architecture, we'd use
this all over the place in RL,
We'll get a couple different baselines
here.
We also I'm realizing here we didn't
actually get to try um
we didn't actually get to try the simple
version.
This stupid thing is immediately better
than the [ __ ] attention
or at least matches. Now it's better.
All right, that's good news.
We can hack on this for a little bit.
This is from the uh the drive
architecture. I think we can probably
mess with this for a little bit and make
a bit of progress.
Everybody wants to do the fancy ass
[ __ ]
Nobody wants to actually solve problems.
multi-agent coordination.
Look at that
coordinated multi-agent behaviors.
That's pretty cool.
Whack a puffer after. Yeah, I got you,
Anesh.
Let me play with a couple more things
and we'll do Wacka Puffer. Why not?
Is it's Is this palm DP?
Actually, no. It's really not to be
fair.
But sure,
cuz the other agents edit this state and
the other agents also learn.
Oh no, the theoretical guarantees are
gone. Whatever shall we do without our
precious theoretical guarantees?
All right. If we get rid of the layer
norm, what happens? Does it explode into
Does it explode horribly?
agents have vision of the task or was it
in look the hard part on this task
pepper is the coordination with the
other agents.
Um this is a problem where there are
multiple targets of each color. You have
to hit a target of your color, but if
another agent hits it, it'll go on cool
down for a bit. So, typically, you just
need to learn to spread out among
targets and watch what other agents are
doing.
What did I say? I got 862.
All right, we get exactly the same thing
without the stupid layer norm. Yay,
we win.
Um,
we probably don't get the same thing
with this, right?
They never do what an intelligent being
would do. There's no reward engineering
here and they're doing what an
intelligent being would do.
So, you're wrong.
The reward is literally get target.
like a human.
I'm pretty sure these are a lot better
at the task than people would be
already.
What about this? Does this cause better
perf?
That behavior is standard.
You've never seen this end.
No benefit.
Okay.
So, this just needed like a simple
two-layer thing, I suppose.
Still play with a couple things, I
guess, right? Um
Oops. I got myself agreement.
Let me
download this and not put this on the
stream.
That's looking good.
Upload this to drive.
and we'll see. Um,
we'll see how this goes.
And if this comes back up, I'll just get
you access to this one.
seems odd to me.
We'll have to double check these OBS.
Uh, we did determine we need the
additional linear layer, right?
But that's not too surprising.
thought you were traveling tomorrow,
Jess.
What areas would you most need
contributors for? Uh, I mean, it really
depends on background experience, right?
If you don't know any kernel dev, we
don't want people who don't know what a
GPU is just like hacking together
kernels randomly. That's not likely to
help. If you do know kernel dev, we got
a lot of kernels that could use work. If
you want to build environments, there
are a lot of cool environments to be
built. If you're on the research side,
there are a lot of cool methods to
explore.
So, you kind of need at least some
background for most of our stuff.
Okay. 858. What did I say that this [ __ ]
got before?
862. So, basically same thing.
Okay.
That's promising.
Let's see if this does anything.
We're just going to fiddle with a couple
things.
Hop on. Learn with us.
Well, I mean, there's still stuff you
can do that with Pepper. It's just now
that there there are on top of all the
stuff you could do before, there also
now more advanced things around as well.
Hello, Elliot. How's it going?
What's happening? Um,
it looks like we're solving the new
little multi- aent coordination
environment with a very, very simple
custom encoder that doesn't require a
lot of overhead. Or at least I think we
can write a kernel for this that doesn't
suck. What do you think?
Do you think we could write a kernel for
this that doesn't suck?
You see the tough part, right? Like
so this thing gets applied independently
to a bunch of different points. So it's
basically a couple matrix
multiplications with an activation, but
you can't actually materialize the
intermediates at all. You have to go
straight from this to the the max dim
right here.
somebody sent me um somebody sent me
like a very optimized version of your
CUDA craft stuff. Um, I have to look at
No, Jess, I tried the transformer and
then we beat the transformer thing with
literally just like a super simple
pointwise encoder.
Yeah,
I'm going to be chatting with I'm going
to be in New York. um later tomorrow and
then I'll be there Thursday, Friday,
meet up with a few people.
I just try to never materialize
anything,
but it's a map mall, right?
So, normally this would get routed
through Kublast,
which is nice and optimized.
So now like this has to go through just
a custom maple I guess that doesn't
materialize.
It's matt mole activation. Matt mole
max.
No use cutless.
Can Cutless even do that?
Wait, Elliot, can cut even do that? It's
the operation. It's M. It's like linear
activation linear max. And you have to
not materialize any of the pointwise
intermediates for it to be efficient.
generalizable is this? This is a very
general op. Um, Jess, you have to add a
couple args to it, but it's a very
general op.
Getting this thing to be fast would
solve quite a bit of difficulty, I would
think.
I don't even think this expansion barely
does anything in the middle.
Let me get you an invite real quick.
Follow.
All right, I sent you an email uh a
link.
Yes, this is percent set data.
Most typically it's when you have
entities like you're encoding stuff as a
bunch of entities.
No, Elliot torch compile is ass for
this.
And uh this would have to go into our
CUDA back end.
We've tried several versions of this
thing with torch compile before and it's
just ass. And also this needs to go into
our CUDA back end anyways.
I do here.
Oops.
What are the shapes?
Um, right now it's just like
you have a query point with two dims.
You have
well, okay, it doesn't actually matter.
Just for linear relu linear max you can
use dim like six for the input
um 128 hidden relu like linear and then
max over the final number of elements
with the 128 hidden
Uh, I can paste it to you. This is new.
Hang on. Let me fix one thing.
I'm just adding a residual.
Deep seek
before flash into quant.
Yeah, let me uh let me just paste you.
Can I stick it on the Discord the uh the
new model?
You see it actually the difference
between this and the version that
doesn't have the um the custom encoder.
So this version can actually learn that
when one of these targets is taken,
it'll go to the other one. And that's
kind of tough for it to learn otherwise
because these appear in invariant order.
So it needs to learn to treat all these
targets set uh as if they're
independently ordered and just like
calculate relative distances.
So this is a way more organic looking
thing. And you can see that the targets
are basically fully utilized at all
times.
Actually I think where is it? I think
that the best possible time is 30.
Yeah, 33. So the best possible uh result
on this task I believe is -30.
So this is basically full solved.
5.5x
high fast.
I suppose I just don't put too much
stock in the incremental improvements
across these models.
Like I'm going to actually go look at
the kernel and see if it's reasonable.
Wait, what?
Why does this not have a size?
Jess, I literally did the simplest
possible thing. I took the um and I also
I took the drive network which was a
little bit more complicated with layer
norm and I just like abladed out
different things.
You can go test it. Sure.
I don't understand this.
Why Why is this not at this size?
Then there's a sync threads after every
Yeah, this is just stupid.
Oh yeah. So you need to do
the max up at the end, right?
It's being weird in a lot of different
ways here.
like
that's tough.
That's tough.
And of course, it's just going to make
more of a mess.
I think we actually need somebody who
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing to do
this one. The thing is this is not just
like the kernel code. This is I actually
don't know what an efficient way to
formulate this op
bottleneck from profiling.
I mean, we're not even at that point,
Elliot. It's a completely stupid
colonel.
like what I'm just I still don't know
what the correct way is to even
implement this
I wonder if we can we stick it in shared
ma'am at least
Jonah on Discord. Yeah, he has. And I
got to merge his his um con thing in
Let's see if we can just stick the whole
thing in shared me.
Jonah,
hang on. Let me look.
L0 diat.
Okay, this is faster than the rest the
mess it wrote for at the least
F16 TF32. too. The mat can be done in
BF-16, but the thing is we're off by a
factor of 100 right now, so that's not
going to get it for us.
You want to accumulate.
Um uh that's a little sketchy. What's
the default? I think that um our our
main map moles for the rest of our
training are um BF-16 with FP32
accumulation. I'm pretty sure.
But again, that's not going to do it,
man. That'll be like maybe 2x.
Like the kernel is 10 times off of torch
now. And then torch is 10 times off of
like the actual op that it should be.
this work if it were only one
projection?
It would, right?
You can't cut out the second map mole
completely. I'm seeing if we can
reformulate it a bit.
Let me just make sure that I'm actually
correct on this.
82.
Uh, okay.
That's irritating.
You lose some by only having one layer
encoder.
I'm not listening to anything at the
moment. Anesh.
You lose quite a bit though having the
one layer
The one layer one layer max is actually
very easy to do.
You can fuse one reduction, but you
can't fuse two when it's they're
dependent.
I'm trying to think if there are any
like obvious candidates here.
a restroom real quick. We'll see what
this does.
Okay, as expected, that doesn't really
help because if that would have helped,
Mingru would have gotten that for us.
should be like this, right? With the one
minus
I mean, Mingru worked so well. Like,
maybe we just take some inspiration from
that.
you know.
something like Um,
807. Yeah, still lacking some perf
grinding matt max. If you think it can
be done, then absolutely.
I'm looking for if there are operations
that are similar and like that do the
same thing but are more computationally
efficient.
it literally just becomes x * 1 - p,
doesn't it?
How much do you want to scale batch
size?
You should be testing it versus torch,
right?
So like um I don't know for inference a
decent number to use for testing would
be like
2048 batch size and then
like the number of points can
potentially scale but you can use the 16
points to start with.
Will you do stream friend NYC? Probably
not. Hey, Plasma.
The container and everything's already
on it.
Try not to mess up host. Just do
everything on the container.
this one. It would seem slightly
surprising if this doesn't work.
It's close.
That's a substantial drop in perf still.
Nope. Torch is not back. Torch has
always just been there for um
prototyping fiddly bits that then get
ported. We're just playing with a couple
architecture encode like a couple
different encoder architectures for a
specific class of problem.
really wants that extra layer, doesn't
it?
Jess, I'm just trying to figure out a
like any reasonable method to handle
data where you have a view of yourself
and you have a view of a bunch of other
things you care about and the order of
those things is um irrelevant.
It's like a specific case that comes up
very often and we have architectures
that work for it, but they're really
freaking slow and hard to write kernels
Four.
Okay. I might come up with a version of
this that makes sense.
I don't know if this makes any sense.
We'll see.
I think that's sufficiently computable
though.
any other form of that that would make
sense.
I got maybe one other thing I can try if
this doesn't work.
I don't know if the other it would be
more complicated is the Okay.
What would this mean if I did it if I
flipped it? If I flipped it so that you
use the
Okay. Yeah. So, this one doesn't work.
They all converge to the same thing
basically, except for the two layer
versions.
Uh, the only other potential hope I have
here is doing this
I actually think this one is also not
computable. We'll see.
Yeah. So, this one I don't even think is
computable. This one will probably work,
but I don't think this one's computable.
I wouldn't be surprised this does quite
well,
Funny enough, this is a very nice
architecture here.
Seems like this one works well.
I think we do have to just solve the
kernel problem.
I've tried basically every variation of
this I could come up with.
Well, we basically need a kernel for
this Oh,
actually, I'm going to keep this one
because this one's kind of cool,
but I think that the uh the simpler one
is going to just win here, right?
Yep. This is just the simplest and best
thing it seems.
This could still be relatively
efficient.
minus 33. Yeah, this is the best scoring
one.
We'll see if that does anything in the
ballpark or not.
post this in a moment. Oh, actually
look, this is good. Maybe this is the
solution, guys. Oh, yeah. Anish, let me
do your end review. I got half an hour.
Yeah, guys, I think this will be the
solution is to just massively reduce
this layer and then do uh this opf fused
at the end.
I think we can actually do it this way.
I think this is a good solution.
Yeah, this perf matches. This is good.
Here, we'll get a gift.
All right, let's put this on a slide
cuz we got a cool policy.
We're going to put it on a slide.
Why is he not doing [ __ ]
Oh, I see.
Uh Jonah, link me the un in the Discord.
I'll give it a quick review.
Where the [ __ ] is the gift that I posted
in here?
Click in review
for your code.
We already have puffer fish assets in
the shared one that you can use, dude.
That people don't have to keep uploading
these, but it's fine.
The way you formulated this is a very
trivial problem.
Like you literally just have to hit the
action that corresponds to the tile.
This is a onestep RL problem.
oddly irritating moving um render logic
into envelope.
All right. Super super simple simple
end. But you know what? Sure.
Oops. I got to check out uh Hang on. I
got to check out um
Check out
full,
dude. How am I supposed to [ __ ] play
this?
Are you [ __ ] me?
Hitting them, but it's not giving me
credit.
Wait, it's not giving me Wait, is it on
the wrong tiles entirely?
I think I got more than that, Jess. And
the thing just didn't give them to me. I
should be able to hit [ __ ] within.5
seconds pretty easily.
All
right, you immediately get to one score
because it's a one-step problem
and for some reason episode return does
not match
The PF of one.
You got to actually make this thing
playable in this.
Of course, it's entropy zero. It's a
[ __ ] like just click the buffer.
Yeah, I'm sorry. I can't do this.
Literally just enter the tile index to
where the puffer is.
I think a I think you can make a better
puffer aim trainer than this
or at least make this one playable.
The code was relatively fine though
and this was funny.
All right. Um I'm gonna have to go in a
few moments, guys. So for folks
watching, I'm going to New York for like
a few days and I'm going to Palo Alto.
So I'll be out for a few. Star Puffer on
GitHub. It's free. It helps me out a
ton. Discord if you want to get
involved. X for all the educational
research, whatever content.
Miss, make sure before I leave that I
don't have my thing screwed up
completely.
Um,
probably like four or five days. Jess,
All right, that's cool.
That's a better slide.
All right, I'm going to call it here,
guys. Thank you very much. I'll see you
when I'm back. Um, check the Discord if
you're in New York and you want to meet